a ghost town of zombie businesses
lockdown is over but football here in
the city of london is still down a
staggering 90
on pre-covert levels up until last week
this chain of sushi stores had hoped to
reopen
but in the last few days k10 has
appointed liquidators
it's over it hasn't really hit me yet
but the tragedy is for our staff
and for our suppliers and our creditors
it's like an earthquake or a toonami
happening
it just overnight like someone flicking
off a switch we've had 122 staff that
are now redundant
economists have euphemisms for this
process structural change they call it
and the bank of england governor says
there's more of it to come i think it's
reasonable to think there will be
what i might call sort of structural
change in the economy coming out of the
covert experience and there will be some
parts of the economy which will just i'm
afraid not be viable going forward there
are often sectors that have a very high
i might call sort of social social
consumption element to them
which involves people working and or
indeed consuming them at very close
quarters
now you have the possibility of a no
deal brexit
yes within your forecast both covid and
brexit
could potentially negatively affect
trade if you're thinking about this
world
covert is the biggest shock now so covet
slightly somewhat dwarfs
i think it does i think i think at the
moment it does dwarf yes
across the river in london's borough
market more customers
slightly more i think we're mostly all
around about 80
down on last year what we'd expect
around this time
there's no office trade there's no
tourists it's pretty severe and um
but there's also on the other side that
i'm just grateful that we're open and
there's a lot of my peers and
friends who have restaurants and they're
closing and it's
so sad like it's a really tough time for
us all
i have two staff that furloughed i can't
see a window
um coming back really
because it's just not the income to
sustain it
it is extraordinary isn't it to think of
just how much things have changed since
the start of the year when brexit was
indeed the big
economic talking point now is something
more fundamental that
question about whether consumption the
engine of the uk economy
may never fully recover from this
if the economy continues to deteriorate
the bank has a new not so secret weapon
at its disposal
negative interest rates if you thought
printing money quantitative easing was
weird well
the next thing to come out of this ghost
town could be even weirder
ed conway sky news